this is a production of Cornell
University
we're really excited about this series
and we were most excited to kick it off
with this one I get to share the screen
with one of my friends colleagues and
mentors Frank dr. Frank Ross the
associate professor of horticulture at
Cornell University he's laughing now but
I want to keep a little background on
our relationship and how it started and
then turn it over to Frank so he can
tell you a little bit about the work
that we're doing with green wood is well
known for its living and collection of
trees and shrubs we curate that
collection we manage it with data it's a
very data-driven management approach to
how we curate it as well we're less
known for the vegetation that's most
dominant though I [ __ ] would and that
would be our turf grass green wood as
well as being an arboretum
is what we call a urban grassland and
urban grassland is really any grass
dominated space within an urban
environment it could be your ball fields
Central Park Prospect Park any of these
places were turf grasses the dominant
vegetation would be considered an urban
grassland what we started noticing
around 2015 were that our traditional
methods of managing our urban grassland
form owing to chemical approached
approaches with herbicide to manage
unwanted vegetation that weren't working
we weren't seeing the control we wanted
on invasive plants specifically for Muta
grass which is a warm season grass and
Frank will talk about that later well we
were noticing a grass that was steadily
taking over the landscape and none of
our approach is working we were also
noticing that mowing caused damage to
our monuments it wasn't effectively
maintaining the landscape from eroding
further and we knew that we needed is
someone who had more knowledge about
turf grass especially in urban
environments than we did so we we I
wrote Frank in 2015 an email I have here
but I won't read it I gave him a lot of
praise I tried to butter him up he took
two years to get back to me
I have consistently called him
throughout this period of time and he
just would reject me every time finally
I convinced him to come down and while
he was coming for another trip and he
saw the extent of the problem Greenwood
is 478 acres largely dominated by turf
grass and it's really showing the
effects of climate change on our stand
of turf grass and how we managed it we
wanted to create a data-driven
management style for managing our turf
grass similar to what we've developed
for our Arboretum and we also wanted to
lessen our environmental impact
that's an inevitability with mowing and
mechanical mowing and herbicide
approaches so we started a partnership
three years ago now with Cornell
University studying Greenwood as an
urban grassland and doing applied
research and now it is my pleasure to
turn it over to Frank Rossi dr. Frank
Ross thank you very much Joe what a joy
it's been for me too I ignored you the
best I could there for a while I was
doing as best I could
giving you the treatment and and your
persistence was I think it's paid off
for everybody and I'm hoping that
everyone sees that by the time we're
done here in next 40 45 minutes or so so
thank you very much all everyone for
joining me us here as we all navigate
this incredibly difficult time of which
Greenwood is really at the epicenter of
and you know the fascinating thing about
what's going on right now is the
relevancy of Greenwood in obvious in the
obvious sense right the relevancy of a
cemetery landscape in the obvious way
where so many people are losing their
lives but at the same time the demand
that Greenwood is facing for as a Haven
as a green space is is honestly driving
a serious concerns to the point where
hey we're gonna need help to control
this now this wasn't at Greenwood but
but this speaks to to me the sort of
pent-up demand
urban populations and urbanism has for
those green spaces and I've been
watching the you know a little more time
on my hands watching a little I've been
watching the Ken Burns documentary of
New York City I'd commend it to many of
you that really don't have a background
of sort of how New York City sort of
leased from Ken Burns's perspective came
about and you see how these spaces you
know maybe weren't originally designed
for everybody when they came about but
boy are they for everybody now and when
you look at the modern scientific
discourse about the way humans are
interacting with their urban environment
you you you can study things that are
allowing us to see the way we feel about
these things and you know you can look
in a paper like this published last year
about people tweeting out of the parks
and in the different boroughs and one of
the things that's fascinating in here is
the happiest tweets came out of Brooklyn
there's a most of the positive tweets
came from being in a park and most of
those tweets in those parks were in the
borough of Brooklyn interestingly there
were more out of park tweets in
Manhattan about parks and and they
weren't always very positive so it's a
very interesting way of looking at the
way we interact with our with our green
spaces in heavily urbanized areas now we
are confronting at the same time that
the demand is very high what's looking
like a very dire situation if you simply
look at this most recent article in the
architect's newspaper here over a
hundred and fifty acres of lawns
untrimmed unplanted trees branches and
hazards what people don't realize about
parks and green space and a Joe is
really a pioneer in his own way in the
cemetery world they don't give a second
thought many times to to grasses to the
trees to the plants right I mean if you
look at what ways a lot of cemeteries a
little laid out and rose to make them
very efficiently manage
when you look at the estate plots that
are found in rural cemeteries like
Greenwood it adds a level of complexity
even greater than what a normal Park
would face and you know you wouldn't
consider okay well you know if the pipes
are leaking we're not gonna fix them
well the air condition doesn't work it
seems to be doing is we're not gonna fix
it
right and so so you know you wouldn't
think of not doing that in a building
right but but we think about it all the
time well somehow green space takes care
of itself
well I'll just introduce myself to you
if you're not aware you know familiar
with who we are at Cornell University
I'm myself as the project director and a
background bolt as an academic and as a
consultant
my current colleague Lowell Chamberlain
our research coordinator comes from a
forestry background and a Peace Corps
background is on site there down and
greed wood with the funding from the
Greenwood foundation and of course the
partnerships we have with Joe and Sarah
Evans the manager of horticultural
operations we it's been a just the joy
working with these folks and furthermore
I'd say in a real homage to the long
history of green wood this this is a
staff dedicated and taking great pride
in their work this is a hard-working
group of people that are really having
to confront a lot of these challenges on
the ground I mean the people that are
planting the grass are seeing yeah you
know it's not working out like it used
to her or boy we see though you know it
just looks doesn't look like it used to
and you wonder and you know we know
everybody's working hard it's just we're
facing some challenges that are making
it more difficult and really the basis
of what I think we've started here at
Greenwood is is a whole collection of
partnerships partnerships around urban
grasslands that engage the expertise
that we have in the natural world not
just in Greenwood but our project
involves professors from the University
of Tennessee the University of Wisconsin
the unit of Oregon State University
Oklahoma State University we've got a
lot of universities now just starting to
notice what we're building here at
Greenwood and expecting and hoping for
long-term partnerships so
what is the goal of this and so
introduced it to a certain extent we've
got a serious issue with Bermuda grass
that's invading the landscape talk about
that and we're noticed that as the
climate is changing
we'd like to not contribute to
greenhouse gas emissions we try to find
a way to get the landscape and Greenwood
the grassland at Greenwood to service
the urban environment and part of doing
that is reducing our reliance on regular
mowing how can we be more systematic
about our mowing so that it results in
an overall reduction now the you know
what I fear when I saw and as I've
learned about Greenwood and what Joe
picked up on immediately and and it's
been you know obvious to people in the
city pay attention to plants notice is
it can somebody mute themselves thank
you when you you looking at Greenwood
really suffering the death by a thousand
cuts you know little things like
south-facing slopes that get some grub
damaged soil insects that start to
degrade this area gets very difficult to
mow obviously you see the chipping away
of the stones that happens from the
mechanical mowing because this landscape
wasn't designed to really withstand
mechanical moley okay so what does it
mean to manage Greenwood Cemetery in an
era of climate change so let's let's
take this apart a little bit and we'll
go all the way to the United Nations and
and who did a wonderful job back at the
turn of the century looking at okay
we're part of this natural world and boy
we learned that in a greater way all the
time whether it's a global pandemic or
what we now see is the real precursors
to a climate in transition and the UN
said listen we need to understand this
better of how the natural world services
us so and how we're impacting that in a
way that's having a negative effect on
us that we simply can't continue to
think the pain
forward is increasing GDP that the only
measure of our success is in increasing
GDP there has to be more of a donut
economics approach put to it that's
looking at sustaining these things that
we need because as we're figuring out
fixing them when they break is not so
easy so in that context we have this
millenium ecosystems report that concept
was then translated into managing urban
grasslands by my colleague Jani gown
effing and her graduate student our
professor at Iowa State University grant
Thompson about ecosystem services what
are the ways that grasslands like green
wood service us they protect us from
certain things they regulate certain
things they give us areas for mental
health they help the soil bill they move
nutrients through they produce they fix
carbon and store it in the soil right
there's so many aspects to what these
grasslands are doing beyond simply
allowing us to walk out there
pleasurably now these things have
started to be monetized it's a
progressive idea coming out of Denmark
what's our willingness to pay for
certain green infrastructure benefits
like recreation and visual
attractiveness right flood protection
right stormwater management look at
where grass strips are involved and look
at the benefits you get from stormwater
management if nothing else it provides
green wood provides 470 acres of
infiltration into the ground possible
infiltration of water into the ground
the recreation that you see the carbon
storage in the soil right traffic and
noise reduction air purification how
much are you willing to pay how much do
you value these things these are the
kinds of studies that places like the
new school can do Brooklyn College and
the urban soil Institute can start to
look at these ecosystem services that
grasslands can provide that can be
monetized and valued in a way
that helps their upkeep be as
progressive as it possibly can be
now as joe said urban grasslands are
really centered around urban centers if
you look at this paper from 2007 by NASA
scientists where they did spectral
imaging trying to find out where the
natural turf grass was in America you
see very clearly it's associated with
urban population centers that are also
intimately associated with impervious
surfaces so where climate change is
impacting our society the greatest and
the fastest in the urban areas we have
the greatest impact of impervious
surfaces with the heat island effect and
the potential benefit that grasslands
can provide so we've got a really a
perfect storm here that's leading to
fairly significant increases fairly
significant increases in temperatures
right I don't have to remind you that
the world is warming now and great irony
the our part of the world seems to be
cooling in a very interesting way and
there's easily acting there's actually
ways of explaining some of this cool
weather that came through around some of
the climate change that's happening an
amplification of these cold affects at
certain times there's this whole study
of the concept of fall spring that's
incredibly fascinating ok let's get back
to what we're talking about here so the
climate is changing
Greenwood is important the grasslands
are really not noticed but have enormous
value beyond what's obvious and what
we're noticing and I think what brought
Joe to me was this widespread
infestation of warm season grasses these
are grasses that grow very differently
than the grasses we normally find in
northern climates if you look beyond
this browning area here if you look
right past here out in here these are
the cool season grasses these are blue
grasses rye grasses fine fescues orchard
grass variety of turf grasses that have
been planted out there over the
purposely and then you get in here and
you see the brown grass not the green
grass in there but these large expanses
of dormant brown grass this happens to
be a warm season grass right and it sort
of gets in and you can see how it
spreads and starts to take over and
gives the landscape a very distinguished
different appearance than we're used to
now the primary species that we find out
there is a sign Adhan species introduced
from Southeast Asia and the Caribbean
probably came in on slate in the ballast
of slave ships that we brought up from
the Caribbean at the time and probably
got put out there now there's other ways
it could have got out there as well as
loved ones might have brought grasses
from other places but again this picture
in the march/april window time frame you
see not many leaves on the trees the
transition of this winter coming out and
you see a landscape virtually covered in
this warm season grass and in fact in
doing some of the modeling we've started
to do on the landscape at Greenwood
we're noticing that the the cardinal
temperature the current models are
indicating that the average temperatures
in Brooklyn
since 1965 combined with the lack of
chilling temperatures have allowed these
grasses to to grow unabated
for much longer periods of time than
they were doing prior to this 1965
period and so we've partnered with a
weather sensor and forecast and growth
modeling company an analytics company
installing sensors in the Greenwood
landscape and developing and
characterizing these microclimates we we
know that the elevation creates a unique
climate in these situations and so we're
trying to study it on a more detailed
level so that when we find and establish
the populations of these plants at
Greenwood and we can correlate it with
microclimate and then use that data to
drive our management of this invasive
species moving forward
but that's meant first office you've got
to understand your enemy here no this is
a plant that will grow about an inch
inch and a half a day you can get six to
eight inches a week we've measured as
much as 14 inches over 10 days with some
plants and we do that by establishing
some experiments in some remote areas on
the cemetery where we carve out an area
we put the plants in and we go out there
on a regular basis and measure the
growth and spread and in doing this
we're looking at not just how it grows
during the season and how it will spread
but how does the way we handle the soil
at green would potentially impact this
and already we've started to notice that
there's a microclimate effect as well as
a soil effect right we've noticed that
the darker soils that the plants and
grasses established more quickly in
allow the Bermuda grass to establish
more rapidly so we see a fairly rapid
spread of Bermuda grass based on the way
we're handling the soil and so now we
want to go back and think about
adjusting the way we handle the soil at
Greenwood a companion study going on in
a nearby area is looking at after we
bury or when there's perpetual care
management done that requires new
seating how does the methods that we're
using and new methods potentially impact
the establishment and invasion potential
of Bermuda grass because of the rate at
which we disturb the ground here and the
competitive advantage that that
disturbance gives the Bermuda grass
we've got to find ways number one to
know how and where and what impacts
Bermuda grass growth and then how and
when and what are the best strategies
for encouraging cool season grasses to
be the dominant species there because
over time it may be if the climate keeps
changing over the next 50 years as we
anticipate
bermudagrass and these other grasses
might be the ideal species but right now
they're leading to increased mowing
increased water use increase we deenis
so there's a number of aspects of having
Bermuda grass out there that creates
some additional challenges so these
methods of understanding man and
containing it integrated into the
greenwood management system is critical
for us so Bermuda Granite's growth rate
increases its competitiveness in micro
climates that favourites growth that's
what we've already began to see and
we're beginning to see that our soil
handling strategy is influencing the
spread and establishment of this plant
so we're currently working on developing
specifications so that green wood will
be able to do this in an improved way
because of the amount of disturbance
that occurs the complications that are
involved there the amount of disturbance
and re-establishment that has to happen
as a general rule we number one are
trying to minimize that disturbance and
here in the background you can see
another invasion of that warm season
grass this is the ravine path you know
that you had to get fixed after
superstorm sandy and so every time we
start disturbing and planting we're
putting in new grasses so what's the
best grass to put in so we established
an experiment on the wisteria area of
Greenwood this past fall and our goal
all was to identify appropriate urban
grassland vegetation for these highly
disturbed locations that have a high
level of invasive plant pressure and you
can see in the background there the
species that were putting in from normal
you know Kentucky bluegrass and low
input low growing fescues tall fescue
that's a more drought tolerant traffic
tolerant species some native grass mixes
to Long Island in the native area there
some pasture mixes that might be what
they would have planted back in the
1800s and then some Bank grass mixes
that
very common when we were planting lawns
in our early phases in the early 1900s
that we've noticed when you have a lot
of bent grass you don't get a lot of
other weedy plants in there in fact Bank
grass competes very effectively with
Bermuda grass and so we're trying it
experimentally out there as well so we
established the new area in wisteria
we've got a fair amount of data and
imagery from that establishment and this
is the typical plot that we plant with
the mix we've designed for Greenwood you
can see it's almost at 80% cover about
34 days after when it's planted in the
fall so you know obviously if you can
plan all your grass at an ideal time we
think we're gonna have a competitive
advantage the issue is we're planting
grass over a three to four month period
in the fall and a two month period in
the spring and it makes it complicated
to have to continue to battle that
Bermuda grass we've taken some really
good data to show the differences across
the board there just to give you a
little bit of it can't have a scientific
presentation without a little bit of
data and so there is the finished
product right now that we're be
monitoring throughout the year we've
been approved by Cornell University and
Lowell who's our on-site research
director there to continue to take the
data for this project so we look forward
to that now let's talk about mowing
right because this is clearly a big
aspect of once we are studying the
Bermuda grass and resurfacing and soil
handling and new varieties and we get
our arms around managing that grass land
vegetation now it's okay mowing is a big
thing how can we be more sensitive to
the climate and the landscape right you
know not disturb it as much not emit as
much fossil fuel emissions not damage
the monuments how can we use data to do
that smartly well we started out by
saying listen this is going to look
different right well for those of you
that might have visited green wood
last year you might have seen some of
the early indications of what I'll talk
about in the middle minute minute about
our perpetual Meadows but we started a
simple demonstration getting some
information out there about how much
emissions we have and how much we can
save and what it might look like and
you'll see this on the chapel law and
adjacent to the chapel lawn but from a
data perspective you know we were
looking at GPS tracking this is the
Internet of Things right this is we had
to go to smart cities and golf course
people to say well how can we do this
even the contractor that we're using to
manage our lands mow our landscape they
didn't have an in-place monitoring
system for their equipment so we were
really breaking new ground in the
management of grasslands using this
approach and it required us to install
antennas and use a low ram Network now I
think we'll be moving to cellular
technology soon but we have a low ram
Network where we've got sensors
installed on the mowers that are
tracking their movement throughout the
property so we can see on this day May
28th of last year that there were 12
pieces of equipment that were out and
about being worked and if you just hone
in on one particular island you can see
that I made 28th island for was mowed
but on May 29th it was not mowed right
so as you start to look at this we're
starting to do this daily data-driven
mowing deployment right so we have the
ability to determine the changes in
mowing that happens how long does it
take the mowing contractor to come back
to this area can we be more specific
about how much we have to mow and how
frequently we have to mow and how
quickly the grass is growing we're
literally measuring the rate of grass
growth now last year in addition to our
mowing work a big emphasis was placed on
trying to cutback mow it so our initial
study
year was about was to put about a
hundred and eight acres into not mowing
them at all after the middle of June we
took took another hundred and seventy
seven acres and said how about we just
mow that monthly and then chain and then
we kept other ones at regular mowing and
other banks and things like that so we
started an experiment last year that
that had a fair amount of difficulty and
and really significantly disrupted sort
of a lot of people's feeling about the
cemetery and there was a real difference
between the way people viewed what it is
we were doing and so one of the things
that we noticed was certainly the people
with loved ones there who had lots had
very strong feelings about you know I
want this mode I need this more
regularly manicured this is a pretty
reasonable expectation that should be
mowed on time and then we have people
who are joining Greenwood and then the
broader progressive question is how can
this massive green space be enhanced to
create in pollinator services or by
allowing it to grow taller in certain
places let the roots grow deeper so they
can store carbon deeper in the profile
right are there ways to use these large
expanses of grass not just a green wood
but at Prospect Park at Central Park at
Governors Island right in Madison Square
Park are there other places where we can
reimagine these grasslands and part of
that is mowing them less so our plan was
to develop a standard for managing these
Meadows right I mean you can see at this
time of year in this picture this is an
aesthetically pleasing picture to many
people especially in the more historic
parts of the cemetery I but one of the
challenges that we have is when we
stopped mowing we started to see Wow
look look at this these are these are
blue stems these are native prairie
grasses grasses that are native to this
area or have made it here from the
grasslands they're in there
either birds have dropped them or
somehow the seed was contaminated and
got in there somehow maybe we brought
soil in at some point that had it but as
we took back the mowing pressure we
noticed wow look at the flora that we
have now I looked at it like that other
people like look cut the grass this
isn't working right but we noticed that
there were places throughout the
cemetery where low slow growing grasses
did not obscure the stones did not
distract they were uniform maybe they
were taller but you could look across
them and they didn't give you that sort
of ratty Nissa pearance that you might
get some cases now here's an example of
one of the challenges that we faced
right in a lot of our Meadows you know
you've got different vegetation up close
you can see we have a newly planted area
where the red arrow is but then when you
look out into the meadow right there
there were obviously the kinds of
challenges that we faced right taller
plants thick vegetation that was
obscuring the stones it's dense it's not
uniform so we've made some adaptations
to the management specifications that
included the way we have to mow it right
you know when you start to change the
management of a grassland right you're
basically taking a system of
professional landscape managers who are
primarily paid to mow the landscape in a
regular fashion you go out every seven
days you you know everybody mows are
long once a week and the equipment is
designed to manage the grasslands in
that particular way and when you try to
make adaptations whether it's a
flowering law or not mowing it as much a
flowering lawn might might limit
herbicide options you could use letting
a grow taller and thicker might limit
the equipment's that you use and so when
we're doing this research particularly
in the practical setting right this is
very much applied research that the
land-grant institution that I'm part
you know what makes this such a powerful
project is that we can not only say well
yeah let's not mow we can try to help
develop on-the-ground solutions with the
mowing company say listen you gotta get
different equipment here this isn't
working and so in working with them
right we we were able to get them to
bring out different try out different
pieces of equipment that has resulted
now in a very different look to these
perpetual Meadows that exist in the
landscape and have been you know I think
very widely and effectively received so
now we have about 40 acres of green wood
about 10% of the grasslands that
represent these perpetual Meadows that
we're managing to a specification right
we developed a specification that now
becomes part of the management of green
wood moving forward so we've been able
to over time number one determine sort
of what are the ways we can look at
reducing mowing and then where we're
going to try to create these meadows
there really aren't good specifications
for the way to do these things in urban
areas I mean some of these
specifications exist for use on golf
courses or in or in restorative prairies
and places like that but you don't don't
see this kind of work done regularly in
urban areas now I think Shirley
Chisholm's Park here in Brooklyn in
their State Park I think they're gonna
see more and more of these parks really
get into more native vegetation
management you know and that's where
it's really you know along a coastline
or in a park setting that has this
aesthetic built in that a meadow fits
that's a bit easier than doing in a
cemetery where the demand has
historically been that this Victorian
view of a very finely manicured of
regularly mode landscape so as I wrap up
for today I'm really grateful to all the
folks that we've been collaborating
and to Joe around various projects and
and Sarah and and and the previous
research director research manager and
Aoife Chadli you know this is a project
that is working as you can city on many
fronts
that we've been trying to co-opt as much
expertise around the country to bring it
to bear on something that really has
been I think primarily ignored greatly
over the last several decades so I thank
my colleague and pal Joe cherub for for
bringing me on board all those years ago
convincing me to come down Greenwood is
in fact one of the great treasures of
the United States and certainly of New
York City so I've been really pleased to
work with work with you guys and and I
think we're just scratching the surface
here I think we've just begun to
understand what are the right grasses
what are the right methods what are the
right strategies and adaptations we have
to make and I think the reason it's
important is now that the public has
recognized the value of these spaces
they're going to need even more
attention and I fear if we just try to
take the way we've always done things
and bring it with us into a post Kovach
world world we're going to create more
problems that we're going to solve so
the progressive types of things that
we've begun to research at greenwood
really aren't answering too many
questions yet but I believe as a good
scientist we're starting to ask the
right questions and by asking the right
questions we got a better chance of
getting answers that will help us move
them forward so thank you Joe I'm happy
to take some questions from the folks
and we can yak about anything moving
forward here thank you very much Frank
that was terrific
really summed all the stuff we're doing
up pretty that's great we have one
question so far what is the difference
between the black soil that is added and
the native soil
the black soil that is added is imported
from a local topsoil source where
there's compost and soil blended it's a
very commonly used soil additive in the
New York metropolitan area in the lawn
and landscape but you'll hear it
referred to colloquially as Long Island
Gold New York Gold there there's a whole
aspect of the soil question it's
fascinating now when you get through so
that's what that black soil is the
native soil is very interesting because
the native soil has had grass growing on
it for 200 years and when you look at
the soil classification it's not well
classified it's classified primarily as
by urban Greenbelt or urban outwash and
simply the elevation change we've been
working with the Soil Conservation
Service and Richard Shaw the New Jersey
State soil scientists - they're trying
to characterize these soils much like
they did at Prospect Park the native
soils are anywhere from fix silty loans
in some areas - gravelly out Washee
sandy material you have the terminal
moraine there where Flatbush starts and
the outwash where they're where the
water receded and the water receded and
the glacier moved on from that point at
the top of Greenwood where the soils
change but the soil itself when you when
you bury someone and you use the
underlying material that isn't really
soil it's a long way of me saying the
native soil is it really soil as we call
it it's mostly subsoil it's mostly to be
horizon that is there after the burial
that the black soil is added - now in
the grass grows on it for 200 years it
gets really good and rich and and can
sustain a grass fairly effectively but
it's also filled with weed seeds amber
you de Grasse plan that's and so we've
been trying to figure out how to deal
with that topsoil long answer to a short
question huh Joe well we can go on to
the soil science section of this talk in
a moment but uh so two questions similar
and then we have a third here the first
is can you talk a bit about bringing lot
owners and visitors around to this new
aesthetic and the next is how do you get
family members to change their mindset
as far as mowing is concerned Joe
neither one of those are questions for
me brother no questions for you I can
try to answer them well let me say why
they're not questions for me and why
this brings up a very interesting
problem I'm a plant scientist and I
think I've chosen I know I've chosen to
study plants because I have a very
difficult time trying to understand
people I have a way for kids and I
understand people at that level but
trying to understand them are the kinds
of things I leave to I think people who
study sociology and human behavior and
there's a whole area of research around
this as a scientist that we could use
some collaboration on but I'd let Joe to
speak to the way they've sort of been
dealing with that at Greenwood for sure
I say that I don't think we did it well
enough the first round
I think the way to effectively do this
is to communicate early and often with
lot owners about our intents and the
reason for our our intervention for the
landscape are primarily motivated by our
desire to preserve the landscape these
are not trying new things for the sake
of experimentation they are for the
purpose of maintaining the landscape as
the environment changes allowing the
landscape to be there for their loved
ones for whomever as we continue to see
these changes so I think that having an
effective communication strategy and
getting out there long before the
interventions are made is the best way
to do it also aligning this with the
conservation component of the site but
there are some people whose minds you'll
never
change some people you know complain to
me and said you know I like what you're
doing
i climate change is real I give to
environmental causes but don't do this
on my Lots and I think for that
constituency it's gonna be very
difficult for us to convince them that
our interventions are appropriate
throughout the landscape but there will
be some opportunities where we can use
these methods where there won't be as
much of a negative response and for
those people who are willing to consider
that the benefits outweigh some of the
aesthetic challenges that they might
perceive I think that's they're able to
be persuaded more readily I don't know
if that yeah I couldn't agree more I you
know I think there are just a whole
bunch of people that just that wait a
minute cut the grass that if you're not
cutting the grass you're neglecting the
site so I think it's important that you
say and we communicate we're doing this
as a means of preservation because this
landscape wasn't set up for the
intensity of mowing that's happening
especially with with the productivity
and the drive to productively mold this
complex landscape and preserve these
stones and the sensitive slopes and
topographical features if they're just
not as compatible as maybe they used to
have been in the past and the assumption
that we really tried to directly compare
last year was that we were doing less by
not mowing as much in fact we never
studied the landscape more thoroughly
than we did when we started changing the
way we mow we knew every every island
every acre of that space and how was
reacting we had to have a more
comprehensive holistic vision of the
site which allowed us to really
understand all of its intricacies and
then apply more specific methods of
control and intervention to those
different areas it wasn't we're no
longer doing a cookie cutter approach
the landscape we're really trying to
take it us
as a challenging landscape it has some
areas that are very different dimension
well and I would just say what what I
thought you were gonna say and what
you've said to me all along is we want a
data-driven approach right I mean we're
never gonna get away away from someone's
intuitive sense to manage something but
a complex landscape like Greenwood has
to be able to quantify certain aspects
of it that we can do in a more efficient
way and that's going to conflict at some
point with the socialized aesthetic
that's one of the ecosystem services
that these landscape provides if someone
comes out there and they're upset by
what they see well then that thing isn't
servicing the landscape is servicing
them the same way whether we can change
their mind or make those adaptations
into management is still what we're
researching I finally I think that the
easiest way to sort of do this is to
listen to people's complaints and to
hear them and and learn from them I
think we've learned a great deal from
feedback that we have received positive
and negative from lot owners here and
it's informed what we've done so
feedback in general has been really
helpful for us Thanks
next question this is from Adam I
assumed that the concept of native grass
may change with climate change as for
from more southern climes begin to
establish themselves permanently at
higher latitudes are we looking more
toward the North northward migration of
ecosystems for the collapse of
ecosystems and species or some
combination yeah that's a great question
it's likely to be some combination right
because you know we don't really know
the specialized relationships that these
cool season grasses that have been here
for 200 years and you know have
developed with regard to the soils and
and the plant either the other plant
material around them for sure we are
expecting a northward advance
we are expecting I don't think we're
expecting a collapse but what worries me
is as we warm and we get these other
plants in the management of that system
is going to drive up a mission
if we're not strategically trying to
manage that transition effectively we're
I I think the the best the best writing
on on this sort of change with these
ecosystems that these different species
talk about it's been really around pests
right I don't know if Bermuda grass is I
don't know I call it a complete pest yet
because we know it might be a role for
it at some point it just sometimes it
doesn't you know it doesn't allow it has
invasive properties now I'll say this
and I'll tee it up for Joe part of the
problem that we're having is we've lost
tree canopy one of the things that
you're driving this invasion is the
increased penetration of sunlight into
these systems so the the problem is from
an ecosystem perspective this thing
wants to evolve back to a hardwood
forest of some sort right and I
personally would like it to because I
know overall that's gonna make the
grasslands you know quite a bit easier
to manage because that's the grassland
that will work in partnership as soon as
the canopy the tree canopy develops
again the warm season grass problem will
be reduced significantly so the way to
manage that transition is to do what
we're doing on the ground from a systems
perspective but at the same time empower
Joe and the horticultural staff to
strategically increase our canopy cover
again yeah that's a great point I mean
that's this is one of the reasons beyond
behind one of our aggressive approach
approach to replanting areas that have
are typically covered in Bermuda grass
but also have the absence of shade we're
trying to re-establish shade they're
both by combination of over story and
understory trees they're to reflect the
rest of the aesthetic throughout
Greenwood which are isn't these sort of
open savanna areas it's it's wooded
areas with openings and we're trying to
basically reestablish those in areas
that haven't had them and the benefit is
our shade which have a myriad of
benefits on our trip grass as well
so next question how much is the support
of native insect and bird populations
taken into account in determining the
management of the perpetual meadows a
great question and not yet not yet that
is where we're going again as a grass
person I've learned to stay in my lane
enough to be able to stabilize that
meadow
so that plants can be strategically
introduced Phase two of the meadow
management I definitely foresee us using
plants that we know us people who are
can tell us about pollinator movement
and bird activity in this area what we
can offer now I'll say this this has
been a prominent area of study and in my
traditional lawn research as well where
we're seeing by holding mowing back
longer in the spring we're getting these
spring ephemeral x' these things that
flower and logs that dont flower
anywhere else same in the fall if we let
the winter annuals or their or some
other plants that are coming up in the
spring we may get some more productivity
out of these plants from ecosystems
perspective the challenge is to maintain
a long period of diverse flowering
foraging plants that are there all the
time that just don't collapse what we're
trying to do is to get the weed enos
that that disrupts those things under
control and then introduce the ones
because the ones that we want and
anybody that studies this this does not
happen by accident I mean the kind these
kinds of systems these planned managed
systems in these urban environments you
know to a certain extent I listen to my
colleague Nina Bostick that tells me
natives made it sometimes lets get
plants that function away we want them
and do what we want them to do in these
heavily designed and managed
environments that can service the birds
and the
so I don't really you know the answer is
we're hoping but there's a lot of
thought involved to doing it
intentionally and the best way for us to
be able to measure that improvement is
by the gathering of data in advance so
we did a comprehensive wildlife survey a
few years ago and we're using that as a
baseline to determine the increase in
the richness of species on-site from
birds the Lepidoptera butterflies and
moths and native bees we're also in Sara
Evans is in the midst of a native bee
survey with colleagues from the American
Museum of Natural History so we're
gathering that baseline data so that
we'll be able to understand how these
interventions enhance their excellent
presence on site
Frank is it okay to walk on the
established grass that green would sit
on the grass yes it is absolutely
positively without question agreed is
Greenwood the only cemetery you were
working with on these matters I should
hope so Frank
Greenwood is the only cemetery that I am
working with on these matters yes
there's yeah only ones the ones that
Missouri right now and but what it
listen we know we're joking but I can
tell you talk about an industry that
needs some disruption I have spent my
entire professional career disrupting
the golf industry
you wouldn't think one person would
spend time doing that but for thirty
years we've been studying doing it with
less pesticides doing it with less
nutrients means doing it with less water
and it's I think it has only been
economic crises and our global pandemic
that's brought attention to a lot of the
research I've spent my time and life
doing the disruption of the cemetery
industry is a much different type of
disruption
it's a socio-cultural thing with the
public more than it is as much as it is
with the management of those cemeteries
there's a very cookie-cutter way these
landscapes are historically managed and
Joe is one of the few that are looking
at it progressively
willing to take the complaints and grow
from it and I think an active
participant in the rural cemetery folks
with our pal up there at UH at Mount
Auburn in Boston I see this only being
more important and and I think we're not
working with enough cemeteries Joe
that's all I can tell you I agree I
think that as Frank said in the intro
now more than ever cemeteries are being
considered these vital green spaces and
the management that's applied to them is
being damaged more considered about how
it's executed I think we have an
opportunity here to reform some of these
management practices that have been long
entrenched because of the
reconsideration of these landscapes and
their value so I hope this is adopted by
any cemetery that could find it
appropriate to use for sure Erin Smith
asks excuse me are there concurrent
studies done with the relationship
between grass and trees I'll say not at
Green would not acrylic but we are we're
doing studies of our trees with with
other collaborators but Frank are there
studies that look at the relationship
between grass and trees yeah of course I
mean you know you you you really don't
have an urban grassland without some
trees right I mean you don't have an
urban grassland without some trees and
generally you have to have one or the
other if you want a really healthy
grassland you need a minimal amount of
trees that allow some light the more
dense the canopy gets the role that
grasses play in an ecological succession
is that they grow themselves out of a
job I mean their jobs to essentially get
that landscape established into organic
matter at the surface right soil organic
matter and then somebody comes in MIDI
somebody somebody or some bird or some
animal drop seed and it starts to grow
and next thing you know it's all trees
so there's enormous numbers of studies
done on the interaction of these things
but mostly they've been the the the the
incompatibility of the grasslands with a
heavy
Caterpie try to make it work together
yes
will there be another winding path
sculpted in the meadow of the hill of
grace yes I believe there will be I
think so
are you hoping that the knowledge gained
here will spread beyond cemeteries uh
other urban grasslands like college
campuses and even residential lawns
absolutely 100% in fact before we got
involved with Greenwood back in 2009
Cornell University here in Ithaca was
actively looking for ways to be more
sustainable which was code for we have
less money what can we do less of and I
raised my hand in a meeting and said I
think we can mow less and we so we've
taken about well I would say we've taken
about 15% of the campus and and mow it
twice a year we've taken about 35% of
the campus and mow it once a month and
we have our highest profile piece of
property live slope for those of you
that know ethica at all is about 10
acres of Perpetual meadow now so we've
tried to do this this is a growing
movement there is fear some people look
at it in urban settings Oh am I gonna
have more tick problems there gonna be
more issues with that and so obviously
there are you know there's some of that
we have to deal with but in general we
have to see this become more popular the
goals the larger picture here is this
concept that Frank and I and Sarah and
all our collaborators are looking to
develop which is this urban grasslands
Institute concept where we use green
wood as a hub basically to promote and
disseminate the information the research
that we're developing at green wood
because of its applicability to all the
other sites within urban environments
and our plan this summer
up until the pandemic was to bring a
student intern down from Cornell that
was going to start doing some outreach
for the Institute for the idea of hey
here's what's going on at Greenwood
let's take some let's look at these
soils at Central Park let's look at the
soils of these things let's go around
with the ground staff and other people
that might have interest in those other
grasslands so we were going to start to
begin to take the early steps of that
but we have the academic interest on the
plant soil side that I think a lot of
landscapes of lack they've had had a lot
of study in the sort of social side but
not as much as this side I I think we're
offer a really unique opportunity to
study this thing for a long period of
time in partnership with the other parks
the wonderful New York City parks that
are that are throughout the city Frank
we've reached the end of our hour here
folks thank you very much for joining us
really thrilled to be able to talk to
Frank and have him share some of the
research that we're doing thank you very
much for coming out and we'll hope to
see you soon thank you all very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu